[Music]
girls you're looking so magical this
morning how are you feeling it's your
first up front yeah I'm really excited
too yeah very excited very excited
nervous excited nervous a bunch of
emotions one you chopped once the most
powerful trio of witches bringing back
charmed it's getting a nice reboot can
you give the fans a little bit of a
rundown as to what's different about
this charmed versus the original I mean
I was eight when Nick meets the original
chance so I I don't know in terms of a
comparison but I know that well I guess
I would say our show is a really sort of
positive fun feminist precursor her too
yeah yeah but I find really interesting
it's about like these three young women
who really love each other and who have
like these powers they're just figuring
out yeah it's definitely an important
story especially right now I'm in
reading it and thinking I oh I feel like
this is a really good representation for
young people who want to be on like the
right side of history I think I'm your
sister
let's do the power breakdown tell me who
you're playing and your powers I play
Macey and I have telekinesis okay I'm
playing Margherita Maggie and I'm I can
read minds
isn't this the girl just one time that
should be nice
I play Melanie Mel and I stop time what
is happening I love also that they
switched it up on the piece to the end
this was that fun for you guys to put
your own stamp on things yeah definitely
I think it's cool to just you know it's
it is a reboot but we're also
lease of life
I mean you know the original would still
exist this is just like a new little
venture and I like because my name
begins with them anyway so it was like
oh yeah my name is Melanie and it was
like the easiest transition there was
like malice as you're playing Melanie
and somebody else wasn't cuz I would
have been so confusing on set Maggie
Maggie and Maggie that was a little bit
Maggie Maggie me well lastly you know of
course the original Charmed girls
they're still out there what are the
chances that we could get them to maybe
you make a cameo on the show I mean you
you really never know yeah I don't know
I feel like the whole team is like so
open to any possibility and like we're
open and welcoming and so nice to be
honest I feel like we've been really
welcomed by the fans so you know I would
welcome I would really welcome that idea
and I'll be also yeah we're sisters
you better together differences are your
strength and nothing is stronger than
your sisterhood
always remember that
[Music]
[Applause]